nasty initiative because
white's night is still wow magnus finds
rookie too brilliant and it might have
been the only move to to to stay in the
i mean to have the equality
look at liam look at liam he missed this
idea he completely missed it and sits up
when magnus goes rookie too what a
stunning move chat and let's ask cha uh
okay peter let's go for it okay i mean
yeah it's i otherwise we designed yeah
that that's true and chad is too too
smart for this spot i think the
difficult move to find was rookie too
what a tactical way of getting out of
trouble and then you just repeat
you say you've solved your problems and
the thing is i don't think black has a
better way but to go for this draw
anymore because you can't give white
control of the e file exactly yeah
otherwise you lose valuable tempo and
yeah wow i mean it looked like this
bishop e6 bishop d5 was wonderful yeah
liam was very sharp between g7 but it's
uh it's just not i mean he picked the
wrong opponent yeah magnus very alert
with rookie too and one could see that
with the speed how magnus played it that
he has long force in it that this will
be his rescue
you know rookie two i have to say i
we've had some amazing chess in this
event so far but rookie two stands out
as a move by itself as a defensive
resource
exactly
that is it
magnus has found a way out of his
troubles with a stunning idea and the
first game between liam and magnus and
in a draw in
quite the style magnus sitting there
probably still checking gets up liam
leaves a slight missed opportunity but
no clear path for liam i think with the
black pieces uh not that big a disaster
yeah no not at all i mean simply that
position was very complicated